today we've seen a mother and father
jailed for what is quite simply an
incomprehensible crime
over the course of little more than a
month Shannon Marsden and Stephen Bowden
assaulted their son Finley leaving him
with 57 fractured bones across his tiny
body
the heartbreaking reality is that
Finley's last days
would have been spent in immense pain a
fact that would have been abundantly
clear to both parents
they knew that they were responsible for
those injuries and instead of doing the
right thing and taking Finley to get
urgent medical care
they took him shopping in Chesterfield
town center
they conspired between them
to ensure that no professional would see
Finley and keep their awful crimes a
secret
but we now know the truth
and they have paid the price with their
Liberty